on Saturday I spoke to the Prime
Minister I updated him on coronavirus
the progress we're making and our plans
for the next few weeks the government is
united in our focus our determination
and our national mission to defeat the
coronavirus and defeat it we will I want
to join the PM in expressing our
heartfelt thanks to the brilliant team
it's in Thomas's hospital and as the
easter bank holiday weekend draws to a
close I also need to thank all of the
NHS staff all of the other frontline
staff who have been working so hard over
the long weekend to care for those
suffering from coronavirus we thank you
we pay tribute to you and we're
immensely proud of all you're doing and
can I also take the opportunity to thank
everyone who followed the advice to stay
at home despite the wonderful weather
and despite the challenges and the
sacrifices that sticking to the advice
presents to many families I have to say
that at the end of last week we were
concerned that people might start
ignoring the advice or cutting corners
given the temptation to go out into the
sunshine in fact the overwhelming
majority of people stayed at home and
understood the importance of doing so
you stuck to the advice you denied the
coronavirus the social contact it needs
to spread and people should be in
absolutely no doubt that by staying home
this weekend you've saved lives and
you've also helped protect our precious
NHS at this critical moment in the
crisis so thank you your efforts are
making all the difference and please
keep them up we've come too far we've
lost too many loved ones and we've
sacrificed too much to ease up now I can
tell you on the latest data that 290
thousand seven hundred and twenty people
have been tested for coronavirus eighty
eight thousand six hundred and
twenty-one have now tested positive and
I'm very sorry to say that eleven
thousand three hundred and twenty nine
people have now died from coronavirus
every one of them our tragedy and
hearts go out to all of the loved ones
who are grieving their loss at such a
difficult time amidst this sobering
death toll there are also some positive
signs from the data that we are starting
to win this struggle but we've still got
a long way to go and as those grisly
figures that I just read out show we
still not past the peak of this virus so
please continue to follow the advice now
more than ever to stay home save lives
and protect our NHS this week sage will
review the evidence of the effectiveness
of the social distancing measures that
we've taken and we will consider their
evidence as that their assessment based
on the evidence at that point I should
say we don't expect to make any changes
to the measures currently in place at
that point and we won't until we're
confident as a confidence we
realistically can be that any such
changes can be safely made in the
meantime the government will continue to
redouble all of our efforts to buy and
deliver the ventilators so we can treat
the most vulnerable in our hospitals to
deliver the master gowns the other
protective equipment to protect those on
the frontline in the NHS but also in
care homes and to ramp up testing so
that NHS and other key staff can return
to the frontline just as soon as
possible
the Chancellor and the business
secretary are working around the clock
to mitigate the damage that this crisis
has undoubtedly done to our economy
getting support to businesses to workers
and to the most vulnerable in our
society so please once again keep
following the guidance to stay home save
lives and protect the NHS if we let up
now the virus will only take full
advantage it will spread faster and it
will kill more people if we refuse to
give in to it if we keep up this
incredible team effort we will beat this
virus and we will come through this
national test our plan is working please
stick with it and we will get through
this crisis together